Here's a very nice demo showing an important technique for cube maps. Up to
this point the techniques described have used cube maps created in advance. In
fact the GPU is plenty powerful enough to make cube maps on the fly. Look at
this demo carefully. What's great about it is that the shiny knot figure and
cube are reflected in the sphere, changing position every frame. The way this
is done is to make a cube map from the viewpoint of the spheres position. The
spheres center in each face of the cube map forms of a view uuu. You render the
scene six times, one for each cube face, and each rendering is then used for
the new cube face. The sphere itself is not rendered into the cube map. After
the cube map is rendered, it's immediately applied to all of the objects in the
scene. The cube map includes the knot and block in it, so you can see these
reflected in the sphere. The exact reflection is not precisely right, but close
enough that we accept it as correct. For efficiency, this same map is used on
the knot and block objects, but the reflections are so distorted that we don't
notice that the environment map is incorrect. That it includes two objects and
not the third. Notice how this demo is recursive in nature. The objects
reflected are also reflective, each object when rendered is using the previous
frame's environment map on it, so, they all look reflective. I recommend toying
with this demo and changing objects and materials to see how it changes what
you see. This technique of generating cube maps on the fly is popular in racing
games for example. The car is removed from the scene and the rest of the
environment is rendered to the cube map which is then applied to the car.
[BLANK_AUDIO]